- Thanks for starting off
your Monday with some Dynamo.
I'm Jason Hunter.
I am a principal solution architect
with a specialty in DynamoDB.
So my job is to try to
know Dynamo thoroughly,
and, oh that's fun.
I got the transcript.
Try to know Dynamo thoroughly
and if you are using Dynamo
and you get stuck, you can
talk to me or one of my peers
and we try to help you out.
You know, if you need a cost optimization,
we'll look at your tables.
If you say, you know,
I'm having a big launch
coming, am I gonna be ready?
Is it gonna handle the
traffic? That's what I do.
Today I'm going to talk
about data modeling
and some of the techniques.
This is a 300 level so I
assume maybe some familiarity
with Dynamo but not extensive.
And so one of the hardest
parts of doing a talk like this
is to figure out how to level set.
How are we gonna start? Do I
assume that you're brand new?
Do I assume that you're here
pretty familiar and wanna level up?
And I kind of have to assume both.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna start with an analogy
of how Dynamo is kinda like
phone books in a library.
And if you're new to
Dynamo, this should help.
And if you're an old hand, it might be fun
to see just sort of an
analogy of another way
to think about Dynamo's data modeling.
And then we'll talk about
some core modeling concepts
using an app that we're
gonna build together.
And then at the end,
what do you do when you
need to scale bigger?
'Cause it's pretty easy
to write a low scale app on Dynamo,
but when you get big,
there's a couple of techniques
you wanna know about.
And if there's questions we'll
do 'em at the end, all right?
So let's start with a day in the library.
And this is an Alex
DeBrie analogy originally
and so I'm kind of stealing
it and expanding on it.
He said Dynamo's a lot like phone books.
Does anyone remember what phone books are?
Are we old enough here?
Yeah, a few of us.
Before your cell phone knew everybody,
before you could Google a name,
you had these actual physical books.
And on the spine was a city.
And so you'd say like, all
right, I'm gonna be in Denver.
And you'd open up the Denver book,
and in there would be a sorted
list of the people in Denver.
And yes, we all shared our
numbers with everybody.
And so you'd find they're
usually sorted by last name
and you could then find by the last name
and by the first name.
And that's kind of a lot
like what a base table is
in DynamoDB, where the partition key,
the thing that you use first
to kind of find your zone,
your item collection we call
it in Dynamo, is the city.
And that's the partition key,
the PK that we call it by short.
And so here we're in Las Vegas
so we're looking at the Las Vegas book.
Inside of there is a sort key
which is sorted by last name
or maybe with a company,
just their regular name,
and sorted alphabetically.
There's a payload with each
item, a phone number, a ZIP,
maybe an entity type, you name it.
This is a lot like what
the Dynamo base table is
because there's a partition
key and a sort key
and you specify the partition key
and then you specify the
sort key to find an item.
But what kind of queries
can we do with this?
Well, given a PK SK combo,
I can get the payload,
I can find people whose
name starts with Hunter.
I can find ones who start with H.
Can I find Jasons? No.
And so if someone is on
Stack Overflow asking,
I'd like to do my sort key
but I wanna do ends with,
what's the answer to that?
There's two answers to that really.
One is no.
The other one is, well if
you reversed your sort key,
then you could do it.
Right?
And sometimes in Dynamo
you do that kind of thing.
Like if you really want ends with
and if you had another
copy of it reversed,
then you could do it.
Can I look up by phone number?
Not with this data model.
By ZIP, no. By entity type, no.
There's some things you can do,
there's some things you can't do,
and that's why Dynamo is so efficient.
Because when you issue your query,
you go to the book, you
find the sorted list
and then you either find
the item or the starts with
or the between or the range,
you know, and that's how you find it.
But if you're thinking
that that's a limiting
set of queries you can do,
that's why we have indexes.
One type is called the local
secondary index, an LSI.
This is where you say I want to have
the same partition key but
maybe a different sort key.
And in phone books, that's
what the yellow pages were.
So for those of us old enough
to remember phone books,
in the back, the pages were yellow.
That's why they called it yellow pages.
And that was sorted by like plumbers
and appliance repairman
or whatever that is.
And so here I'm doing a
sort key of casino or hotel,
and now I've expanded my ability to query
'cause I can go say hey,
find me casinos in Vegas.
It's not hard. Or hotels also not hard.
So this is one way to think
about what the base table is
and an LSI is an
automatically updated thing.
When you update the one,
it kind of propagates
into the other one.
It gives you another way to query it.
What can we do and can't we do?
I still can't look up
by name or phone number
or ZIP here.
I could do the name
against the base table.
There's another thing called
the global secondary index.
Nothing to do with
global tables by the way.
Common naming issue we have there.
But in this case you say you know,
I might want a different partition key.
And so instead of looking
by city as the book,
maybe I want by ZIP code as the book.
And that would be a smaller
book probably usually.
And in there would be its
own sorted list of names
by that ZIP code
if I have name as the sort key on my GSI.
And so now I can say well
I know he's in Denver,
I know he's in this ZIP code,
and I can pick which one
I want to do as my access.
Make sense? And so what can we do?
We can do now a different partition key
and possibly a different sort key.
I've chosen here to do
the name as the sort key.
What else could I do?
I could do a phone number as a sort key,
and then I could find a certain
phone number and a ZIP code.
What if I wanna look up
by phone number in general
in the whole database?
Then I would have a
GSI with a phone number
as the partition key.
And that would have a different,
that'd be very little phone books.
There'd be like kind of like a little book
for every phone number in the world.
But then going to the partition key,
I don't even need a sort key.
Sort key's optional in Dynamo.
I could look up by phone number.
So one copy of the data
and then you use these indexes
to pick the different ways
that you wanna access it.
And that's the basic
way that Dynamo works.
Always with a PK and an optional sort key.
All right, how are we gonna
wanna update these things?
The easiest way to do
it is we're gonna update
just the base table
and we're gonna let the
other ones propagate out.
They're a little bit different
between LSIs and GSIs.
LSIs, because they're
in the same phone book,
you know, the white pages and
the yellow pages together,
that one's done strongly consistently.
When you update the base
table, the LSI is updated
at same time 'cause it
went to the same place.
GSIs are in a different kind of place.
They're in like a whole separate books
and a whole other set of shelves.
That one is eventually consistent.
People want strongly consistent.
I look forward to the day
when we get that.
We don't have it today.
But if you update the base table,
it will usually in a millisecond,
but it can be longer,
propagate over to the
global secondary index,
and then you only have
to update in one place.
And, guess that works.
If we think about storing this stuff,
I picture a library holding the books.
And so you know, I'm gonna have a library
and on there is gonna be
a whole bunch of phone books
that I have to go find.
But do I want just one library?
What if there's a fire?
What if one of 'em is down, right?
What if there's road construction?
It's hard to get to one of 'em.
Well, let's keep three
copies of the phone book
and let's separate them by, you know,
a meaningful distance,
possibly in different availability zones.
And then we'll make Dynamo
into a regional service.
So if even one availability zone is down,
you've still got two other copies
and life continues.
It's great that you don't
have to think about this.
You don't have to think about subnets.
You just talk to a public endpoint
and we've got three copies of your data
across three different
availability zones all the time.
And how do we update if
we have three copies?
Well, amongst the three nodes
they will elect a
leader, and it'll rotate.
You're the leader then you're the leader.
They kind of do a vote, and one
leader gets all the updates.
Now when you're doing Dynamo calls,
have you ever seen that you
can do a strongly consistent
or eventually consistent read?
Strongly consistent says go to the leader.
You know you always have the latest data.
Eventually consistent says
any of the three will do.
And you got a small
chance of seeing something
that has not had the full propagation.
A write is durable as soon as it hits one
and the other one acknowledges as well.
So you have to hit the two.
The third one, we don't wait for it,
we acknowledge it after the two.
And so if you do an
eventually consistent read,
you might get that third
one that is not necessarily
as caught up, but eventually
consistent reads are half price
and eventually consistent
reads have three targets
instead of one which
increases availability.
Make sense? All right.
And then this is where I think
it really gets interesting
'cause most people with Dynamo
who've been doing it for a couple months
understand all that.
But let's understand how partitions work.
I think there's a common misconception
that a partition key
makes its own partition
and that's not how it works.
Think of it that in the physical library
we have to have our books
on shelves, all right?
And each of these shelves
acts like a partition.
They're only so big, so
we have to figure out
how many of them we wanna do.
How many shall we start with?
One seems like not enough.
10 seems like quite a lot.
Let's do four. And why
did I pick four here?
A default on-demand table actually creates
four partitions on the backend.
We had to pick a number that was enough
to handle decent amount of traffic
but not so much as to be wasteful.
You don't wanna have more
partitions than you need.
So by default it does four.
If you've heard about warm throughput,
that's where you can hint
to a on-demand table.
You're gonna be a big
table, start out big,
and that would increase
the number of partitions
on the back end of a table.
And that's a really nice feature.
Now with cloud formation,
you can in an on-demand table
say start large, you say
that you want a lot of reads
and a lot of writes.
I have seen enterprises that
go live with an on-demand table
and they didn't do warm throughput
and as a result, the first hour,
they're sending more traffic
than a four partition
table would wanna handle.
And so it splits, as I'll talk about here,
but it takes a little bit
of time to do the splitting.
All right, so first thing we have to do
is figure out how do we
assign data to shelves?
How do we assign items to partitions?
I think the obvious one
is alphabetically, right?
If you go to a library,
you're probably gonna find
the cities alphabetical.
That's pretty good. But we don't do that.
And why not?
We don't do that because city
names are not evenly spread.
I'm from the Bay area.
Everything starts with S.
It's a San this or a San that, right?
So if we did that
and we didn't know
about what our data was,
all the data would kind of
go to the same partition
if it was alphabetical, right,
everything would end up on the
last one here, Q through Z.
So what else could we do?
Well if you want a nice even distribution,
the easiest thing to do is hash the name,
hash the partition key.
Now you're gonna get nice distribution.
Even if the partition keys
are very lexically similar,
they'll hash all over the place
and now you're gonna
get a nice distribution,
where about one quarter of items
naturally end up on each
of our four shelves.
And that's why you'll
see the partition key
called a hash key internally.
'Cause we hash.
I kinda like the hash key name more.
'Cause the partition key is
what leads people to thinking
that a partition key means one partition,
but what it is is that
we hash the partition key
to help determine where it goes.
But you don't get a whole
shelf for each book.
Each shelf is only so big,
so at some point we're gonna fill it up.
I start with a table of four partitions,
I keep loading data.
At some point we're gonna
say all right, that's enough.
In Dynamo the enough
is around 10 gigabytes.
So if you've loaded enough, a
partition gets around 10 gig,
we're gonna start thinking,
hey, maybe we should
do something with that.
What we do is we split it.
Generally when it gets
big we split it in half,
right in the middle,
and now we have two
different shelves there.
We split the 40 to 5A, hex prefix,
in half with the 5B, 7F
being the other half.
And now we can add more space.
And so we do this all the
time. In the background.
A table that's been around
a long time is gonna have
a lot of partitions 'cause as data grows,
we're gonna be splitting
it on the back end for you.
Some edge cases.
What if a city, or maybe a ZIP,
but like especially a city,
what if it gets bigger than a shelf?
What do I do there?
The answer is exactly what
you do in New York City.
If you ever saw a New
York City phone book,
it wasn't a book, it was several books
where they had split it by the last name.
This is A through H or
something and so on so forth.
They split by the sort key.
And we do the same thing. We
split by the sort key too.
If we see that it gets really big,
we can split that thing.
Right in the middle of an item collection,
we can split the partition.
With a caveat. This is a pro level caveat.
We can't do it if the table has an LSI.
'Cause remember the LSI,
the idea is that I have
the white pages and the
yellow pages together
in the same physical place.
So I can't start splitting the white pages
in three because now I
don't have a good place
for the yellow pages to go.
This is why if you have an LSI,
you can't have an item collection
bigger than 10 gigabytes.
'Cause of what's going
on underneath the table.
We are like, nope.
An item collection has to be contiguous.
A book has to be one book,
which is a downside of LSIs.
The upside is the strongly
consistent read nature.
The downside is you can
never get rid of 'em.
Once they're on a table
you can't remove them.
So they're at table creation,
and also they limit how big
an item collection can be.
10 gigabytes is a pretty
big item collection.
It doesn't hit a lot of people,
but it is there as a rule.
All right, something else that
happens in the physical world
is that there's only so much traffic
that can go to one of these shells.
Each partition has hard limits.
Do we know what they are in Dynamo?
Each partition gets 3,000
read capacity units,
1,000 write capacity units.
And that's a hard limit there.
At some point it gets a lot of traffic.
Too many people are coming to write
or too many people are coming to read.
So what do we do about it? We split.
So we can split the books across shelves
if we think it would help.
So before and after.
We've said this one book is so popular
that we're just gonna split it
into its own item partition.
This item collection, 'cause it's a book,
an item collection gets its own shelf
and now that item collection
can have up to 1,000 writes
and 3,000 read units per second.
What if everyone wants the
same item in that book?
We can actually split one
item to its own partition.
It goes down to that level.
So you can, in Dynamo,
if you're gonna really bang on one item
and you're gonna update
it 1,000 times a second,
you can, you can update it, you
can read it 3,000 read units
with eventually consistent reads.
That would be 6,000 calls.
So you can read the same
item 6,000 times a second
because of how we split it.
Now, you don't get it the first second,
but we will very quickly
split when we see the traffic.
Split for heat we call internally.
And if you Google up
split for heat Dynamo,
you'll find a blog that
has me testing this
under all kinds of circumstances
to see what happens under pressure
and you really quick expansion,
and the order of minutes, right?
So hopefully now if you're new to Dynamo
you kind of get a sense
of how Dynamo thinks
and why it's a key value store
but with a sort key as well.
Not just simple key value.
And if you've seen Dynamo before,
maybe that was a little
fun trip to the library.
So now let's think about
some real data modeling.
Let's make it real.
So first thing. A table
has a partition key always.
You get to pick the type.
String, number, binary.
We like string a lot because
string is very flexible.
If you wanna do it with an account number,
you can, we're there for you.
If you wanna do a binary, you can, fine.
But we kinda like string
and we sometimes like
to mingle our strings
to say what they are.
Like a customer ID string,
we might say CUSTID#123,
hash being a common separator.
We do that because later on this table
I might wanna store something
that's not just a customer ID.
We a lot of times like
to use the same table
and put different kinds
of things in there.
And if I have a partition
key that's a string
that self describes what
it is, I have that choice.
You don't always have to,
but a lot of times we'll
name our partition key PK
and our sort key SK,
and that way we're very
flexible of what's coming.
I actually think if I were
to create Dynamo today,
I might say I'm not even gonna
ask you for names and types.
They're going be PK SK, they're
gonna be strings, the end,
and let's just like get rid
of the whole idea of schemas
and then you tell me.
But you know, SKs are optional,
so I guess you'd have to
at least tell me that.
You can't change a key value if it is
an indexed item of partition key or SK.
You have to delete it and reinsert it.
You can change a payload attribute
but you can't change one
of the index attributes.
All right? So what kind of
partition keys do you see?
A lot of times you see a
descriptive one like Zip#89109,
and this says this is a ZIP code.
I know that 'cause I put
a ZIP hash in front of it.
Sometimes, as we'll see
later when we start sharding,
because we get so much
traffic we wanna support like,
more than 1,000 writes a second,
we might add a suffix at the end, #01234,
and that way I'll have more
partition keys to write to
to handle an influx of data
that's coming really quickly.
Comes a little bit later.
And sometimes we see multi value.
In multi value, it's
like I have a ZIP code
and a type together,
and you can do Zip#89109#type#casino.
It's up to you. Or you
just do 89109#casino.
It gets awkward.
Has anyone seen the announcement
from about a week ago
where we now let you do
multi-attribute partition keys
and sort keys?
On GSIs. Not on base
tables yet. But on GSIs.
So this whole main goal
to have multi values,
you don't have to do it anymore for GSIs.
Really nice. Why?
Because when you do a GSI sometimes,
you're like you know, I want a GSI lookup
and I wanna do where it's in this ZIP code
and it's of this type,
and if you didn't previously
on your base table
have an attribute that was
those two joined together,
you now have to write to
all your base table items
to have something to project
into the global secondary index.
That's a lot of writes.
It's a pain on you.
Now you just say I'd like a GSI
and I'd like it to be
synthetically created
as if these were joined together.
And we're like right away
boss, no base table writes,
no ugliness in your base table,
no increased storage in your base table.
I love a good feature.
So that's a very nice feature
that we just introduced about a week ago.
Too recent for it to be on the slides.
When you see sort keys,
sometimes you see 'em typed.
Like Name#Hunter or whatever.
We do that because a very
common convention in Dynamo
is to have a partition key be the thing.
It's a customer, it's a device,
and then the sort key prefix
is like the different things
that you know about it.
Like for online shopping,
I might have address
and then I might have another one
that's like your credit card
and another one that's like your orders,
another one's your shopping cart.
And the sort key prefix
is like a description
of what we know about this.
So it might be like
order ID 1, order ID 2,
order ID 3, and I'll remember the orders
that this person previously did.
We call this single table design
because we do different entity
types in the same table.
And it's popular because
if I wanna learn about you
in one go, I can just go to the database
and make one query call
and bring all of it back
really fast cheaply,
'cause one quick call,
and we price by the
amount of data returned,
or at least scanned.
So that's a common convention
and we see the typing here
when we're doing such things.
Sometimes people put a timestamp.
It's a pretty common sort key.
If you have a device
and you have different
measurements at different times,
we see the the timestamp there.
And sometimes you see hierarchical.
Like country, state, location,
and that way, because on a sort
key, I can do a starts with,
I can say starts with USA
and I can read everything in the USA,
USA NV and I can read
everything in Nevada,
USA NV LAS and I can read
everything in Las Vegas.
So that single sort key gives me
three different access
patterns by doing this.
Again, this is gonna be
nice with the new feature
because it's a little bit more expressive
than you having to think through
it's a string and I'm prefixing.
Now you can just say where these
three things are like this.
Oh yeah.
It's syntactic sugar
and I got a sweet tooth.
All right so let's put it in action.
A somewhat realistic example.
So I have to dream up an example
of something we all know.
Here's my only AI in the talk.
We're gonna design a schema
which is a history of a chat bot.
So you ask your questions,
you get your answers,
and I need to remember this history
so that I can feed it back to the chat bot
to remember the state when you come back
and things like that.
So I'm gonna try to scale this big.
I'm gonna have millions of users,
threaded conversations
and each conversation
has its own specific metadata.
All right, doable.
What are we gonna do?
Here's some requirements.
Given a user id, I wanna
pull all the threads
and thread metadata.
Just gimme everything about the user.
I'm building the interface,
I'm gonna the left
sidebar with everything.
Given a user and a thread,
pull just that thread.
Okay, so not everything
but just like I expand a thread
and I wanna see what's in there.
Okay. Given a user id,
pull a recent thread.
So like pull the last stuff. Okay.
It's always fun when you get requirements
and you have to think of a schema.
I think it's pretty obvious
that the partition
key's gonna be a user ID
because every one of these
requirements is given a user ID.
And one of the nice things of Dynamo
is that you know if I
solve it for one user
and that user works well,
I know I can solve it for a trillion users
because of how each
partition key can be isolated
in the database to its own
partition if I have to.
And even smaller sometimes.
I know that it's gonna scale out.
That's the scale to any level.
So you can often think about your world
as did I do well for one partition key
and the amount of reads
and writes that it accepts,
and if so, it'll scale to whatever I need.
And you can sleep well at
night without any surprises
because there's no dependence
on what one partition key
is doing with another one if they've split
to different partitions.
So the PK is going to be UserID,
the SK is gonna be thread
metadata and thread messages.
So this is pretty common convention
where you have one item
in the item collection
that is like the metadata about it,
and then a bunch of other
little payload ones,
maybe by timestamp here
with a create time,
which is gonna be each message
and the time of that message.
Pick your thing, you can do
IDs, but times is easy to model.
And so given this, given a user ID,
I can pull everything by just
saying no sort key constraint,
give it everything.
I can do a sort key
starts with a create date
and thread ID, and I can learn
everything about that thread
as long as I know the date
and the thread ID together.
And I can also pull recent
by just saying start at the bottom
and sort backward by time,
maybe pulling in batches
of 50 or 100 or whatever
until I've read enough.
And that'll get you the last ones.
'Cause it says recent
threads, it isn't specific.
So I'm just gonna be able
to go in the sort key,
starting at the bottom and go back up.
NoSQL Workbench is a
client side application
that we often use to visualize our data,
and here is a screenshot from it.
This is all for one user ID, 12345
We see a sort key which is the timestamp
with, yep, down to the seconds.
And then we have threat
IDs, user IDs, all that.
Notice that the bottom item is
different than the first two.
It is meta, so that bottom
one has different attributes.
It is a metadata about this.
And this is weird for relational people
'cause they're like
wait, did you just switch
attribute names in the middle of a table?
I sure did. I can do that.
It's NoSQL. It's one of
the things you can do.
And so what's nice is I
can, for a given thread ID,
just pull all this stuff in one go.
Even though like one's
metadata and one's the details.
So I've satisfied the requirements.
But you know how the real world works.
They gimme more requirements.
All right, what's the new requirement?
Given a user id, I just
want the thread metadata.
You just want the meta
objects across all threads.
All right, that's harder, right?
With my current model,
I would have to scan all
the detailed messages
to get the metas.
I just want the metas, I
wanna pluck out the metas.
What do I do? I have indexes.
A lot of times when you have an issue
about a different access pattern,
you think I have indexes.
So we make a GSI, and we're
gonna make a GSI that's sparse.
Sparse meaning not every
item in the base table
is going into the GSI.
When you do sparse ones,
it's kind of nice because
you pay by the storage.
You don't have much storage.
And you pay by the writes and
you don't have many writes.
So a sparse GSI is a very
affordable construct to create.
I'll have the same GSI partition key,
but I'm gonna have to have a sort key.
You know what?
Anything, anything that
I put on the meta item,
which only exists on the meta
item, will be my sort key.
If it exists, it goes into the GSI.
If it doesn't exist, it's out of the GSI.
And that's how we make a sparse GSI.
You do it on an attribute
that's not always there.
And if I do this,
then I have a nice GSI
ready to query just for you.
And so it looks kinda like this.
This is two different users.
12345 and 67890 and their metadata items.
When you project into the GSI,
you can choose which
attributes you wanna project.
You can project all of them.
You at least have to do the keys,
which is the partition key and sort key
of the base table, they get projected in.
And so now I can read just the meta.
It's kind of a nice optimization.
When you do this kinda stuff,
you think how often do I want to do this,
because I could brute force it
by just reading the whole
item collection, you know?
But if you're gonna do this a lot,
then I probably wanna spend
the effort doing the writes,
the write cost, to save
my read costs later.
So a lot of read versus write trade offs.
Oh, but I said GSIs were
eventually consistent, didn't I?
Huh. What do we do about that?
Well one thing we can do
is we can just say yep,
GSIs usually, you know,
tens of milliseconds,
a lot of times it's one
millisecond, 10 milliseconds.
Are we okay with that?
I'm gonna get the meta
and how fast is this really anyway?
A lot of times we just do that.
Sometimes you say, you know what?
This is my time for an LSI.
I'm gonna create an LSI
'cause I need the strongly
consistent nature of an LSI.
You just gotta be careful, right?
Because it limits your
item collection size.
You can't delete an LSI after
creation like you can a GSI.
Another thing you can do
is you could dual write.
You could say I'm gonna manually
insert into a thread table
and into the main table,
and you can pick which one goes first.
'Cause sometimes it's okay
if it's like in the meta
but it's not in the main table.
And if you read it,
you're like oh it's all
right, it'll come in a second.
Lemme try again. If you're
kind of doing this yourself.
But you have the chance
that your program crashes
in between the two writes,
and now you've left a
dangling index entry.
So another thing you can do
is a transact write call.
We have transactions,
and you just say insert
these into both tables
and it succeeds or fails as one unit.
Transactions are twice the
cost of non transactions.
So, if you like that, how
often are you gonna do it?
You know? Do I wanna pay double?
Do I want the GSI that's
eventually consistent?
It's your choice.
All right, so up to this point,
this is pretty standard Dynamo stuff.
I feel like using Dynamo
for lower scale stuff
is like weight lifting with lightweights.
You can really do it with bad form
and still succeed, you know?
But now we're gonna lift the heavy stuff,
we're gonna deadlift 500 pounds.
Like, all right, let's
talk about form exactly.
So first thing.
We were successful, this
was great. Reduced costs.
You always get this call as
a database person, right?
You launched, it was good.
You were doing things with scans, right?
Scans is where you just scan the table
to find what you want.
Just like a relational
database full table scan,
you can do it at small tables.
It gets expensive for big tables.
All right, so let's see, what can we do?
First thing is I noticed that user message
and bot response, which
are the big text fields,
are just stored plain in there.
And there's a cost with
Dynamo for storing things.
There's the storage unit.
You pay by default in US
East 1.25 per gigabyte month.
There's the write units
because writes are charged
by the kilobytes written.
There's the read units which are charged
by the four kilobytes read.
There's Point in Time Recovery.
That's a kind of backup where
you keep a write ahead log
and it is proportional
to the size of the table.
And there's backups which are costly,
proportional to the size of the table.
So the smaller your data,
the smaller your bill.
So if you ever get a chance to
reduce the size, you should.
So what do we do? Well the
easiest thing, we compress it.
We store the data as you hand it to us.
If you wanna hand it to us compressed,
we'll store it for you in
that way and you'll pay less.
You'll pay fewer writes,
you'll pay less on all
the storage aspects.
So gzip and lz4, two, ones.
I did a little math, fake data here,
and lz4 was a little superior.
So let me point you that way
if you're gonna pick between the two.
But what's the pros and cons?
The pro is way less space.
The con is like I can't do
a filter against the text
in the database now 'cause the database
doesn't know what the text is.
The database is blind.
I hold a payload, I
don't know what it means.
But a lot of times you don't care.
In this application, I
don't think the database
needed to be able to read that string.
You weren't indexing it or anything.
Maybe if you moved it to another system,
but then the other system
would have to do the decompression.
And another thing that
might not be as obvious
is if you have a lot of little attributes,
model, model version,
temperature, top P, top K,
max tokens, all this stuff.
Sometimes if it's just payload,
you're not gonna index on 'em.
You're not gonna filter by them.
You don't need the database
to be aware of 'em.
They just need to be handed to the client.
You can make it into a
JSON, a MAP in Dynamo.
You can compress that, store
it as a binary in Dynamo,
and now you've got a smaller set of data.
It also serializes a
little faster I think.
So, might not always think about that.
You can also do just a string.
Sometimes people have like
a lot of little attributes.
You can make one attribute with a string.
It's a little tighter as far
as its internal representation.
It's not a huge win, but it is a win.
Again, if you don't need the database
to be aware of what it
is, a way to save money.
Another thing you see.
How much does it cost to
update an item in Dynamo?
The answer is it's proportional
to the size of the item.
If you update one little value
in a six kilobyte item,
it costs six write units
because it's the larger
of the before or after.
How much does it cost to do a delete?
It costs the size of the item.
So one thing that you
see people do sometimes
is they have like a
timestamp in our meta here,
which is the last update time,
and the meta is six kilobytes
in my hypothetical example.
Huh, I'm doing a frequent update here.
What I could do instead is I
could break it into two items,
a static and a dynamic portion.
I could only do my updates in the dynamic.
Now my writes are one instead
of six. Is that good or bad?
I think it feels good.
It's bad if you never do the update
because the initial write
needed to do two items
and maybe the first one was like 5.8,
which rounds to 6.
And then you also have
to do the other one.
So that's 7. So maybe
the initial write is 7.
And later on you get the 1-1-1.
So I'd say it's a win
so long as your update is
often enough to math out
that I'd rather pay 7
plus 1-1-1 than 6-6-6-6.
And this is a common thing.
One of the fun things is
when you're doing video games
and you have to keep a list of things
in your knapsack, right?
Do you wanna have like one knapsack item
which is just big, but every
time you change your knapsack
I have to rewrite the knapsack?
Or do I wanna have every
item in the knapsack
be its own item?
Discuss. It's a challenge.
Do I wanna have little knapsacks,
like every unit of update is a knapsack?
What is the best way to store n-many items
for a video game player for their payload?
And this gets into it.
The cost of writes and
the cost of storage.
Oh man, these people keep
coming up with requirements.
Okay. Users can now
delete threads. All right.
And the threads might be really big.
All right, so what I
probably don't wanna do
is have the user wait around
while I'm actively deleting.
What do we do?
This is a classic soft
delete situation, right?
Where I'm going to mark
something as deleted,
act like it's deleted from
the user point of view
and then later on in the background
do all the sweeping, right?
All right. Hmm.
I'll update an attribute
on the metadata item.
I'll delete the conversation later.
How do I know which threads are deleted?
Almost every one of these has
an answer as an index, right?
There's an index on the deleted threads.
Okay, I can do that.
So what I will do is I'll create a GSI,
I'll make it a sparse GSI
because it'll only be the
deleted thread metadata.
And now if I delete a thread,
I will create a new attribute.
I don't care what it's called,
but it will be the attribute name
that gets projected into my sparse GSI.
And then I can go to that GSI
and I can see only items
which are representing deleted threads.
So maybe I will pick a GSI
partition key of a thread state
to say it's deleted, and a
GSI sort key of a timestamp
of when it was deleted,
so that I could like clean up
the oldest first or something.
So I go here and I do a query,
and I say find me in
this GSI partition key
equals S# delete.
What's the S#? State? I'm
doing that name mingling thing.
You see that a lot, you don't have to,
but I'm doing it.
T timestamp, T representing timestamp.
And I can say, all right,
find me all the deleted ones forward,
gimme the first 10 and
I'll go off and actually
actively delete them.
Is there anything wrong with this?
We're in the scaling section.
We're in the one
where we try to say, you
know, how do we do this
when the scale gets to enterprise level?
One of the issues is that in that GSI,
the partition key of deleted,
it can only accept 1,000
writes a second, right?
Are you gonna delete more
than 1,000 threads a second?
Most people don't.
Some people do.
So what do I do about that?
And this is actually where you
get a lot of hot partitions,
as we call it,
is the base table has a beautiful
high cardinality partition key.
But the sort key has like
state as the partition key.
I chose this here just
because it's so common.
I wanted to get it out there.
And the state can be an issue.
So this is where you can shard.
So if I was gonna do
10,000 deletes a second,
then instead of deleted,
I would have like deleted# random number,
and now I can accept as many items
as 1,000 times the unique
number of partition keys.
So maybe I should do 20
so that none of 'em
are close to being hot.
All right. This is sharding.
You'll hear it all the time there.
I'd love a built in
feature but it's not there.
But this is where you have to be aware
that sometimes my partition,
my one partition key
can get more than 1,000 writes a second.
Now we will sometimes be
able to split it for you,
but if you do this, you're
guaranteed it'll work.
The details on when we
can split hot partitions
is kind of complex.
Happy to talk about it, but I blogged it.
If you do that Split
for Heat DynamoDB blog,
it tests out various scenarios.
All right, so what if later
I have more values like archived?
I mean, I can do this.
S#archived0123456. S#somethingelse012345.
Another way I wanted to show you though
is that you can just
pick the partition key.
You don't care what the
partition key is that much.
So look at this.
Now my partition key is S.
I don't know S, shard?
S stands for shard now.
Yeah, that works.
Shard012, as many as you want.
And I've moved the
value into the sort key.
So now I can do a query which
is like give me everything
in S0 bucket there, S1 bucket.
Or I could say S1 starts with S#deleted.
And now I can say gimme
all the deleted ones
from the bucket 1, and I could now find
all the deleted threads
by going to my 10 buckets,
and for each one saying,
gimme the sort key starts with this.
And I just wanna show this
because sometimes you put a value
in the partition key
and sometimes you put at
the prefix of the sort key,
and they both work just fine.
I think this one's kind of elegant.
I don't know.
I pick as many shards as
I want 'cause I'm like,
well I'm gonna update this many times
and I'm gonna have X many shards.
And then the value just becomes something
that goes into the sort key
as opposed to me having
all these partition keys
with all the different values there.
But there's no real difference
from the database performance
or the cost or anything.
It's just a style thing.
All right.
Boy, these people keep
coming up with requirements.
I wanna count the total
cost per model per day
and I wanna count the total cost per model
for each user to do some billing.
Okay, and this is one of those situations
where I probably don't wanna
put it on the main write path
because if I put it on
the main write path,
I slow down the user
and there's really no need for that
to just do my accounting.
This feels like a backend thing.
And so I wanna scale to any usage
and I want to not make the user wait.
So have we heard about
streams in DynamoDB?
Streams are Dynamo's change data capture
where every mutation
that happens to a table
will be put into a stream
and you can then watch that stream
to do something with the data.
And some people do this
if you're doing a shopping cart checkout,
they'll be oh, the order placed,
and then they proceed
to propagate it down.
Sometimes people do it to
propagate to a downstream system.
So I can watch that and I can push it
into some other database
that's gonna have a different index model.
Or I can write it to S3
or I can check for bad
behavior or whatnot.
And you can also do event filters on it
to say I only wanna be
notified about certain things.
And there's a tight
integration with streams
and Lambda where you can
create a Lambda function
that says I watch this stream
and it's just called for you.
You don't have to iterate streams and all.
There's a lot of work
to go find the latest
data out of the stream.
But if you hook up with
Lambda, it's all done for you.
And so you create a Lambda function
that updates the count and would
probably buffer internally.
So a Lambda will be handed,
not just one item at a time,
but some batch of items
and you can control that.
So you can make a bigger batch,
and you can have 1,000 items
and you have your Lambda
be like, all right,
let me aggregate this together
and update once instead
of update 1,000 times.
That saves write costs
and it improves efficiency
because probably the
Claude model on one day
across all users is going to be used
more than 1,000 times a second.
So better I update with a buffered value.
It kind of depends on how
accurate you need to be though.
Streams are really nice
because they are exactly once delivery.
You don't find this often in
any sort of streaming event.
They're exactly once in order
delivery out of your database.
Pretty cool.
But if a Lambda function
has issues, what happens?
If a Lambda crashes we restart
it with the same payload.
So you gotta be careful because the Lambda
might increment once and then
die and then be restarted,
then increment once again.
So you gotta be careful when
you're doing the Lambda stuff.
And there's no simple
straightforward like,
push a button and it's all good.
You basically have to
have some state remembered
where the Lambda can know if
it already did the work or not.
One technique is that
you'd make a message ID set
in the item of recent updates.
Like hey, I'm doing an update
and I hashed my payload and here's my hash
and let me make a note
that I did the work,
and here's a recent set of work.
So if I crash and I come back,
I can say, did I already do it?
Did my previous incarnation do this work?
If so, I'll skip it.
You can also maybe use transactions
with a client request token,
which is a way to get
item potency out of it,
so long as you can get a deterministic
client request token out of your payload.
'Cause the Lambda is
always, well not always,
it's usually invoked with the same payload
unless you say split on error,
in which case it will split
it down to different payloads
to try to isolate the error out.
But it's complex enough
that I wrote a blog on it
with I think seven or nine or some such
different ways to do it.
All of which are a little bit like, okay,
as a technical term.
So you can look up that if
you wanna see ways to do this.
But I wanted to point that out.
When you're doing the Lambda processing,
the stream is exactly once
in order, perfect delivery,
but your processing of it may not be.
And then something else.
Gosh these people, this PM,
they keep making all their
money giving me work.
I wanna be a PM someday
and make other people solve my problems.
So service-side search.
Right now you can do a client-side search,
search your past chats, but
it's gotten a little slow
'cause it's un-indexed.
So I'd really rather
have a server-side search
that I maintain for everybody.
What do I do with that?
What's the query in Dynamo
that does tech search?
Yeah, there isn't one.
Was anyone excited?
Like really? There is
one? No, there's not one.
So what we do though is we
integrate with OpenSearch.
So there's Zero-ETL,
I think this was about
two years ago introduced
and you can without
having your own servers,
it's all serverless and managed for you.
You define the configuration of how Dynamo
will propagate to OpenSearch
and then have a copy of
your data in OpenSearch,
or a subset of your data if you want.
And against OpenSearch
you can do all the stuff
that is advanced indexing.
'Cause OpenSearch is
really about index tools.
So you can do relevance ordered search,
you can do an analytics
type query, you can do RAG.
And we have a workshop at
3:00 o'clock that I'm leading
where we're going to do
this actual integration,
where we're going to use
OpenSearch and Bedrock
and do natural language
processing with RAG
driven by OpenSearch and vectors.
So this is one way to do it
with Dynamo and OpenSearch.
Pretty straightforward.
You'll see that there's just a definition
of this goes to there and that's it.
So then one last tip.
And I just put this in all my talks
because it's gonna save you so much money
the day that you need it.
So this is your money saver.
This pays for your reInvent ticket.
The new requirement is we wanna be ready
to recover from an
application level corruption.
So something went wrong.
a bulk load happened.
I deleted an item I didn't mean to.
That level of corruption.
It's our job as AWS to make sure
that your database doesn't corrupt,
but it doesn't mean that your application
couldn't make a call that
you didn't mean to make
and actually did something
bad with the data.
And the thing you do with that
is a push button.
You can turn on Point
in Time Recovery, PITR,
and PITR maintains the
change log for up to 35 days.
Now you can configure it smaller
if you wanna forget things after a day.
But we will remember
up to 35 days for you.
And against that you can then typically
do a full table restore before the damage.
This is you after doing the bad load.
You're like, I'm gonna get fired.
I can't believe it.
So you just ran a bad bulk load.
And the full table restore is
a way to solve the problem,
but it costs $150 a terabyte.
15 cents a gigabyte is a way
to make it sound smaller,
but it's $150 a terabyte, right?
You might get fired, man.
How big is your table?
So what else could you
do? There's a cheaper way.
And the cheaper way was
introduced two years ago.
Anyone remember? It is called
incremental export to S3.
If you have Point in Time Recovery on,
you have access then to
doing an incremental export,
you can do a full export too.
We've had that for a long time.
An incremental export
though is where you say,
I want the list of changes that happened
between these two points.
Give that to me as JSON on S3.
So now, think about it.
If I get this on disc,
which tells me the time,
the partition key, sort
key, if there's a key,
the primary key of the item,
the old image and the new image.
I can see that at this
time I changed Mary Grace
to Mary Smith.
I can now undo the damage
without having to go make
another table, right?
One is restore a table.
Now I've got two tables,
I gotta delta them,
I gotta figure out what happened,
and then put it back.
Or I gotta point to the new table.
But that's awkward, right?
'Cause you can't rename the
table to be the old name.
You gotta point at the new name.
But here I can just do
an incremental export.
I can then process it and say, all right,
items for this set of item collections,
these partition keys, these
are the ones that are bad,
roll it back.
Whatever is the old image,
make that the new image
basically in the table.
And the cost is what? Well,
it was $150 per table here.
Incremental export is 10
cents per gig of log size.
And assuming that you had
like a gigabyte of logs
during the time window of your bad load,
it changes $150 to 10 cents.
There you go.
Bigger if you have a a larger table.
And the recovery time from hours
to restore a 10 terabyte table to minutes
to export and process the
export and be able to do it.
So I'm just putting that
in my various talks.
If you ever hit the PITR issue, be ready.
You should probably dry run this.
But then that's a way to undo the damage
if you ever make a mistake and not get,
did you wanna go back?
All right, thanks for coming.